(hardcore rock music)
- I listened to sad music on the bus
hoping that it would make me
cry and someone might see me.
- When I was 14, I used to
dye my hair with Kool-Aid.
- I was the emo kid.
Every Spirit Day at school
was my favorite excuse to wear eyeliner.
- I once Tweeted, "We're
all islands shouting lies
"to each other across
seas of misunderstanding."
- I think all good books have sad endings.
- I was the emo kid.
I wrote sad poetry every
day in high school.
- I wrote a LiveJournal
post after every break-up.
- As a kid I used to watch
The Nightmare Before Christmas on repeat.
I was the emo kid.
People used to judge me for my crazy hair,
and they still do.
(birds cawing)
(whooshes)
(sign squeaks)